vous quelques jours michel david et
bénévole aux restos du coeur depuis
bientôt deux ans à 76 ans cet ancien
médecin à la retraite ne devrait
pourtant pas être l'âme qu'ovide oblige
la direction a demandé aux plus de 70
ans de rester chez eux
michel lui aussi a peur du virus mais sa
place est ici tout ce qui est possible
de faire pour éviter la contagion on le
fait ici est donc dans ces conditions là
on peut pas non plus empêché de vivre et
de faire ce qu'il faut on peut pas
laisser les gens sans nourriture parce
qu'il ya un vide dans l'yonne la moitié
des bénévoles des restos du coeur sont
restés chez eux depuis le début de
l'épidémie
les distributions comme ici à auxerre
continue elle chaque semaine
et colmate les brèches en faisant venir
plus de gens et
et plus d'heures sur ceux qui viennent
ils font un peu plus d'heure
[Musique]
distribuer sur deux jours au lieu d'un
on y arrivera mais disons que les gens
fatigue ça saute
car l'autre conséquence du coc vide
c'est l'augmentation de bénéficiaires +
30 % depuis le début de la crise
sanitaire
à auxerre les restos du coeur distribue
chaque semaine plus de cinq mille colis
alimentaires du jamais vu ici on redoute
toujours parce que nous on est là pour
aider les gens et quand ils font une
heure une heure et demie de l'attend
dehors ce qu'ils ont besoin
alors évidemment nous notre notre but
c'est lors de nice qui leur faut donc
évidemment on est toujours un peu
angoissé les restos du coeur manque
surtout de chauffeur pour leur tournée
dans les communes du département
faute de nouveaux bénévoles la situation
pourrait s'aggraver alors même que la
campagne d'hiver doit débuter dans moins
de deux mois